hi there steve kaufman here uh i haven't
done a video for a while i have a new
computer i think the quality here is
going to be better
i want to talk today
about uh
what it means to be a linguist
and about input-based language learning
uh i will put in the notes to this video
reference to two uh
posts on my blog
one is
one where i go into more detail about
the definition of a linguist and and how
we can all become linguists
uh another one is a reference to um
an article by professor bloom at the
university of chicago on the history of
of language learning and input-based
language learning i particularly
recommend the article by professor bloom
very very interesting
i want to talk about linguists because i
am regularly criticized here
if not here then at my blog which i call
a linguist on language and typically
people say you can't call yourself a
linguist
you shouldn't be offering advice
about language learning because you're
not a linguist
you don't study linguistics you don't
know all these linguistic terms
um i will also post uh here a link to a
youtube video put out by a christoph
cluckston
where he also criticizes me
for calling myself a linguist and you
might listen to that if you're
interested he also delves into the whole
um
you know benny the irish polyglot issue
and so forth
but so let me make it very clear if you
um
open any dictionary of the english
language
uh i believe and certainly if you open
the oxford english dictionary which i
have done you will see that the first
definition of linguist is a person who
speaks more than one language
i think a lot of english speakers have
not even heard the word polyglot
to them a linguist is someone who speaks
many languages
i don't think that linguistics
or linguists are necessarily
involved in language teaching although i
guess there is a field called applied
linguistics but i don't think they have
been very helpful
uh in
uh making it easier for people to learn
languages in other words to become
linguists
because they have a tendency to
complicate things
introduce complicated terms whether it
be terms of grammar or terms like
phonemes and morphemes and i don't know
what other kind of themes
so i don't think you need to be a
linguistics expert you don't even need
to be an expert in applied linguistics
to offer advice on language learning if
you have learned a number of languages i
think you have useful
and potentially valuable experience to
share with other people people can form
their own opinions
and they may be stimulated by what you
say or not stimulated or turned off by
what you say
so that
to clarify a linguist is someone who
speaks more than one language
i believe that
many many more people in the world could
be linguists because it's made too
complicated now in that regard
the article
by professor bloom is very interesting
because
it's not just today that we feel that
language teaching has been made too
complicated
this was an opinion expressed by john
locke the british philosopher in the
17th century
there's another mr hamilton i can't
remember his name but you'll see the
details in the article by professor
bloom who points out that
you know in the middle ages people learn
languages by reading
and they had interlinear translations
and you know abundant glossaries to help
them through these texts and by reading
subjects of interest
they acquired the language and that they
acquired it more quickly that way than
uh in subsequent centuries when the
emphasis was more on on grammar and
instruction
so that uh it's an interesting and also
this article about professor bloom
points out justin how important
vocabulary is
that while a small number of words may
account for 70 or 80 percent
of the uh
of most contexts
in fact the remaining 20
consists of a lot of words including a
lot of relatively rare words so that to
participate in an intelligent
conversation beyond just you know
ordering beer
requires a lot of words and of course
all of that is behind the way we have
structured link we have sort of a modern
equivalent of these glossaries
in the way our little link widget works
which we're constantly improving
now you don't even have to go to the
dictionary the meaning slots in right
away
uh with our flashcard being built in and
we're expanding our notes section to
each lesson so that
because the objective i believe as a
language learner is to get to real
authentic meaningful texts as soon as
possible again christoph plexton
criticizes me for not realizing he
believes i don't realize
that um
krashen was
promoted this idea of comprehensible
input
um you know i know that but
i think that we can help make input more
comprehensible and if you can combine
uh comprehensible input
with making it interesting then that's
going to be much more
uh effective for the learner because
you can't start with comprehensible
input you know at first the
comprehensive
comprehensible portion isn't 95 percent
it's zero percent and you work your way
up from that and if you have the audio
and if you have the glossary or the
kinds of uh functionality that we have
at link you can work your way through
these texts and i remember doing it
within three months of being in russian
i was attacking russian novels because
that's what interested me
so
yes again cluckston refers to total
physical response and other teaching
methods which are fine there's nothing
wrong with these they're probably quite
effective but it requires a classroom
for tpr whereas all i'm saying is and
again benny the irish polyglot is always
in favor of charging off to the country
and speaking to people and corralling
people to talk to and stuff and in
certain circumstances that might work
it's not something that i would choose
to do
but all i'm saying is there is this
other
tremendously easy
approach which is to focus on input and
to build up your vocabulary so that you
can understand what people are talking
about so that when you do have an
opportunity to speak you're going to do
better but the big advantage of the
input based approach
is not only that it was effective as you
will see if you read
this article about professor bloom it
was effective way back in the middle
ages
but it's all under control you don't
rely on the good will or indulgence of
some native speaker has to talk to you
while you try to babble
you can decide what you're going to
listen to
and nowadays with mp3 players with the
internet with all these wonderful things
it becomes easier and easier much easier
than it was in the middle ages to access
interesting content
uh
just a few other things and with
reference to the uh
to the clunkston video
he sort of implies and benny does the
same that uh i'm only interested in
reading and i'm not interested in
speaking but that's not true and people
shouldn't like shouldn't ascribe motives
to people when they don't know uh to me
input based learning is the fastest way
to get to effective communication
uh to benny listening to mp3 players and
reading is inhuman or anti-social or
something okay he doesn't like to read
that's fine
i think reading
is is
tremendously powerful in your own
language and in learning other languages
we have a disagreement but don't assume
that i don't like to speak and similarly
clarkston uh
you know says oh moses mccormick speaks
all these languages but he never has a
chance to speak them
benny lives in europe so he's actually
learning languages that he can speak
well
in fact
you know when we talk about the joy of
being a linguist listen to a few of
moses's
videos tell me if he doesn't enjoy
speaking those languages
tell me if he doesn't enjoy meeting some
an estonian or someone from i don't know
cambodia or kenya i don't know all the
languages that he's learned
he enjoys doing that and and why is that
not a good thing why can't how can you
criticize someone for doing that and i'm
quite sure
that that moses
knows that his 15th and 20th language
better
than benny knows his czech and hungarian
or his tie where he went amidst great
fanfare and and claimed that within two
months he was going to learn that
language so
to each his own i mean
i'm not saying that benny didn't pick up
anything but
to criticize people who have a somewhat
more systematic approach
i think is unjustified and
we are all going to follow the the
method that we enjoy the most because
ultimately that's the key is to enjoy it
and so to summarize here a linguist is
someone who speaks more than one
language
there's a tremendous amount of of
enjoyment and joy associated with being
a linguist and
consuming massive amounts of input not
only 95 comprehensible
is very effective and it has been sold
historically and hopefully now with
internet and mp3 technology it will be
again
thank you for listening